first wave so even if you put aside all
the modern-day challenges when this
happened in 1918 it came in three
different waves so let's be prepared and
intelligent some of the lessons to learn
the CDC did a fascinating report that
have put out on May 1 which starts to
take a deep look at what happened and I
think there's a lot of important
information in that and it pointed to
something that we've been looking at
here in New York the report says that
when they look at the different strains
of the virus in the United States that
there are different strains and we were
all looking at the West Coast the West
Coast had cases well before the East
Coast remember maybe six weeks before
the East Coast those strains came from
China what we saw in the state of
Washington what we saw in California
they came from China flights from China
land predominantly on the west coast
what we have seen in New York didn't
come from China but actually is a
different strain of the virus that came
from Europe that's an important fact to
know and to study they then said in this
CDC report from February you had 100
39,000 travelers coming from Italy 1.74
million from other European countries
where the outbreak was spreading wildly
and rapidly so everybody's looking at
China meanwhile the virus had traveled
from China to Europe was in Europe
spreading from Europe we had European
travelers coming they come to the East
Coast they land in New York they go to
New Jersey they go to Connecticut
they're in the New York
area and we're all still looking at
China we were looking at China and the
travel ban on China may have been
helpful but the horse was already out of
the barn in China the virus had left the
virus was in Europe and meanwhile we
have European travelers coming here and
they're bringing the virus which is now
a different strain of the virus to the
East Coast this is from that CDC report
the deputy director principal deputy
director d'Alene travel bans allowed for
the virus to spread throughout the
United States and contributed to the
initiation acceleration of domestic
covered cases in March extensive travel
from Europe once Europe was having
outbreaks really accelerated our
importation in the rapid spread the
timing of our travel alerts should have
been earlier that is a very important
fact and something we have to learn from
a person from the Grossman School of
Medicine knowing the number of flights
coming into New York from Italy it was
like watching a horrible train wreck in
slow motion this nobody was watching
Italy in Europe at the time nobody was
even thinking about it today we must
consider an outbreak anywhere is an
outbreak everywhere
Ajay Parkinson and I think that's those
are words to remember going forward
outbreak in China in a number of days
it's going to be in Europe from Europe
it's going to come to the United States
assuming it didn't come from the United
States immediately from China another
lesson we have to learn is our hospital
system you know we talk about our
hospital system we don't really have a
public health system we have a hospital
system and we learned the hard way about
the capacity the equipment and the
management of our hospital system New
York City we have only 12 public
hospitals they are the Health and
Hospitals corporation
operation the run by New York City but
there's only 12 hospitals in that public
hospital system 44 hospitals are private
hospitals they're private institutions
they're regulated by the state but they
are private institutions they have their
own area of expertise they have their
own base of clientele and they're doing
business as individual entities like an
individual college right we don't we
have a system of colleges but each
college is individual it's the same
thing with hospitals each hospital is an
individual entity Long Island we have
four public hospitals where we have 19
private hospitals Westchester one public
hospital 12 private Rockland one public
to private Hudson Valley the rest of the
state two public hospitals 87 private
hospitals so really your health care
capacity in this state is all in the
hands of private hospitals right you
have a hundred and seventy-six private
hospitals in the state that's the
capacity but that means you have to now
rely on those private hospitals get them
all to be part of one system which
day-to-day that does not happen
they're operating themselves we have
again state regulations that say this is
how much you must operate but they
operate as individual entities in the
middle of this outbreak we had to go
back and do what we call the surgeon
flex management system where we said to
all 176 private hospitals we have to
work together and we have to manage this
system as one because hospitals are
getting overwhelmed maybe within the
public system they can share patients
and doctors and staff because you have
in New York City
HHS 12 hospitals ok you can share among
your 12 but
we have to get these 176 hospitals now
all to work together even with the
public hospital and hospitals were
getting overwhelmed so now you need a
system to share patient capacity share
equipment share ventilators share staff
that had never been done we did this all
basically on the fly and we put together
a pup de facto public health system but
it was a lot to do on the fly and we
need to institutionalize these lessons
part of what we have to learn is what
happened with the equipment I mean this
was just a situation that nobody
anticipated it happened all across the
country you couldn't get enough gowns
you couldn't get enough masks we're
going to put in a state requirement now
that every hospital has to have a 90 day
supply
stockpile their own stockpile of all the
PPE equipment that they could need for a
90 day supply at the rate of usage that
we saw with this kovat virus so every
hospital has to have 90 day supply
period we can't go through this day to
day moving masks all across the state
right this mad scramble that we were in
and still are in in many ways also as a
nation we can't go through this again
there was competition among states there
were competition among private entities
to get this equipment the federal
government was trying to buy it I'm
bidding on behalf of New York we're
bidding against other states Texas
California other states of course the
country are trying to buy the same masks
from the same vendor we literally won
the bidding up the price I'm have people
in China I'm trying to contact people in
China who can figure out how to buy
masks from China it was
totally inefficient and ineffective the
state of Massachusetts governor Baker
was good enough to work with Robert
Kraft who had a personal airplane that
he sent to China to get masks and
Massachusetts was good enough to give us
some of the masks that a private
airplane picked up I mean this is not
this is not the way to deal with this
situation right plus we just drove up
prices by our own competition there was
a limited supply it was primarily in
China and then you have 50 states and
all these private entities and the
federal government trying to buy from
China it just it made no sense so let's
fix that New York State alone buy is
about two billion dollars of medical
supplies this year two billion dollars
this year and that's one state and
that's us purchasing from China and
around the world we're going to form a
consortium with our seven northeast
partner states which by about five
billion dollars worth of equipment and
supplies that will then increase our
market power when we're buying and we
will buy as a consortium price as a
consortium for PPE equipment ventilators
medical equipment whatever we need to
buy when you put all those hospitals
together all that public health capacity
together which will make us more
competitive in the international
marketplace and I believe it will save
taxpayers money I also believe it will
help us actually get the equipment
because we have trouble still getting
the equipment and just buying the
equipment because these vendors on the
other side they're dealing with
countries they're dealing with the
federal government why should they do
business with one state right when they
can do business with an entire country
so this consortium
think will help us get the equipment and
get it at a better price we will come up
with a regional identification of all
the equipment we need basically it's all
standard equipment a mask is a mask a
gallon as a gown let's come up with a
total amount that we need let's stop
doing business with vendors who we found
to be irresponsible
and we found out the hard way I can't
tell you how many orders we placed with
vendors who were acting basically as
brokers who just started businesses in
the middle of this pandemic because they
saw an opportunity so let's compare
notes among the states to find out who
was good to do business who was not good
to do business with let's see if we
can't do the purchasing in this country
and let's see we if we can't do the
purchasing in this region now why are we
buying all this material from China
literally billions of dollars of PPE and
we'll do it in coordination with the
federal government but I want to thank
our neighbors our neighboring states the
word neighbor has a different
connotation you don't normally think of
the surrounding states as neighbors you
think of the person next door is a
neighbor but they are neighbors and
they've acted as neighbors I can't tell
you how supportive governor Murphy New
Jersey and governor Lamont in
Connecticut and all the other governors
in our coalition have been literally
where you can pick up a phone and I can
say I need help with masks do you have
any extra masks do you have any extra
gowns can I borrow this can I borrow
that really the way you would deal with
a neighbor in an extraordinary
circumstance right you'd knock on the
door and say can I borrow this that's
how these states responded and it was
really a beautiful generous way of
operating that that was an inspiration
to me you know it wasn't I'll have my
lawyer call your
it was whatever I can do I'll do
and in that spirit we want to keep that
coalition together and we want to work
together we're doing regional planning
now on the reopening because every state
is linked to every other state we do
something in New York it affects New
Jersey Connecticut Delaware etc people
are very mobile right now so it's a very
important relationship for us both
productively and from a an efficiency
point of view and they have been great
and they're joining us today we have
Governor Phil Murphy with us governor
Ned Lamont Governor Tom wolf and
Governor John Carney and we'll start
with our neighbor from the great state
of New Jersey Governor Phil Murphy
how are you governor Murphy beyond with
you
I will be brief and say I echo literally
everything you've said including the
conference on the altar in terms of what
this is bit like the deficiencies as
well as the inspiration with which was
derived from our our difference notably
beginning with you and all the other
governors who are on this today it has
been truly an inspiration
go on behalf of the nine million that
was in New Jersey I say thank you you
know we were we were in the state note
we beg borrow and bartering for
equipment PPE ventilators etc we're
still doing it someone said to be couple
days ago that balance can become the to
ventilators and so we're still out there
until the notion of coordinating
together as a region makes enormous
amount of sense it's tightening up
inside New Jersey uh we've moved in New
Jersey alone 21 people in the past two
months a line of business we were to get
beforehand it makes so much sense it
really looked forward again if you
suggested we coordinated actively as we
hold our government in a lobby regional
council will be put into the governor's
on today is but also when I'm
Massachusetts this is a perfect
extension
of that relationship but I got though
one of your your comments that not only
should not have to be scoured in the
world for this chronology made the USA
and better yet made in our states and so
that's something that I think we all
want to strive for we're doing that New
Jersey look you're out a way to make
this cup here and lastly and you said
this we've all got to do within our own
or also the regional cooperation matter
so much a great example of that it's a
brilliant extension of our our ongoing
cooperation and then lastly none of us
is in the partnership with government as
you rightly point out we have all of the
with what's good for our own citizens
with people in the region and work
closely a federal government every step
of the way thank you for having me not
today thank you to each of my governors
in this group and really looking forward
to working with you in the better day to
head thank you thank you very much
governor Murphy I think the governor's
on this phone we've we've learned so
much about PPE over the past few weeks I
think we can go make gowns ourselves at
this point I think I think we've learned
now give us some sewing machines I think
we can we can actually contribute so
thank you very much Phil god bless you
and stay well and anything you need we
hear thank you we'll go now to Governor
Lamont great state of Connecticut
governor Lamont thank you very much for
being with us and thank you for all
you've done not just for the people of
Connecticut but for the entire northeast
good to be with you ned and and back at
new york and edgar crumbles that are
very for the neighbor of course and as
you know we got into this together we
realized what we had to do when it came
to closing down parts of our service
economy we did that together we're
opening it up together and that's the
way it works best and as you point out
when it comes to the purchasing look
we've learned something right we can
wait for the national stockpile we can
wait for that plane to land in China
let's see what we could do ourselves and
as you point out we're much stronger
together
I wouldn't mind having some of that New
York purchasing power thanks for sharing
that with Connecticut going forward and
just as importantly um what we can
produce together well I mean Phil Murph
you got that amazing pharmaceutical
industry era New Jersey help us out with
the reagents and what we can do in terms
of uh gowns from being produced in Rhode
Island but we can all do together to
make sure that this next round we
control more of our own destiny
and to those to say you know where
you've been and you're ordering up all
the Christmas trees and they're gonna
arrive on December 26th I say I'm afraid
this is still pressed beginning as you
pointed out Governor Cuomo and we're
planning for the next round of this if
there is a next round making sure that
we control our own destiny going forward
we do a much better together thanks for
getting us together Andrew no my
pleasure thank you very very much
governor on your right look we're
spending billions of dollars why not buy
from our own vendors in our own region
why are we buying from China right I'm
sure there are a lot of businesses
within our own states that if they knew
they had that kind of purchasing that
they were looking at that they would
either adopt their businesses or grow
their businesses so we could buy from
them a plus you're right we would
control our own destiny rather than
everyone trying to figure out how to buy
from China so thank you very much
governor Lamont god bless you we're here
thank you
let's go now to Governor wolf from
Pennsylvania good to be with you Tom
thank you very much for everything
you've been doing ad thank you for being
a great neighbor to the state of New
York and all your surrounding states
thank you good well thank you very much
for organizing this again a few weeks
ago we all got together and announced
that we were going to work together to
fight this this pandemic and we said
then
by working together we can do a lot more
than we can do with each of us works on
our own and I think today is a specific
example of that we can work together to
buy the things that we need to allow our
healthcare systems they have a capacity
it needs to fight this this fight we
need to help our hospitals we need to
help our healthcare workers we need to
help our long-term care facilities our
first responders all those things and
what you're doing here and what we're
doing is actually pooling together to
make sure we're doing all those all
those things and part of this is testing
it's not just the equipment we really
need to work together to build the
capacity to test it we're not going to
be able to give our citizens the
confidence they need to go back to work
they're not gonna have the confidence we
need them to have to go back to school
or go back to the store or to go back to
worship so all those things are really
important and by working together we can
we can pool our financial resources it's
really important as significant as you
pointed out governor cuomo we can
actually pull the brainpower that exists
the great institutions in our in our
areas and the manufacturers who can make
this stuff all that we can pull together
and and if we can do that with with even
with something as difficult as testing I
think we're gonna make sure that we get
through this in the best possible way so
thank you for pulling us together this
is really important and I'm proud to be
with you thank you thank you governor
wolf and you're so right look we are
we're creating in some ways new
industries right who ever heard of the
testing industry or the tracing industry
or these reagents that all these tests
now use even the demand on PPE
I mean this is a whole new world for all
of us but there's also an economic
opportunity in it and we should take
advantage of it because we need it and
it's not going away and it's going to be
a major industry going forward so let's
make sure it happens here but Tom thank
you very much thank you for all the help
and thank you for everything you're
doing really you're an inspiration to
all of us thank you Tom and we have
Governor John Carney with us from
Delaware
John thank you very much for being with
us thank you for all the help thank you
for all the support thank you for the
friendship through all of this which is
also very important just the the
personal support is important as we're
going through this as colleagues thanks
for being with us today John yeah thank
you
Governor Cuomo for including Ella we're
in this coalition thank you for your
great leadership there in the state of
New York and particularly Metro New York
City with your colleague governor's on
either side of you you're an inspiration
frankly to all of us our hearts go out
to you as we see the numbers I was
really happy to see your numbers on the
chart at the beginning of your
conference today as they trend downward
that's really a very good and positive
thing and thanks for including us a
state of we like to refer to ourselves
as a stated neighbors there's just shy
of a million Delawareans here on the
southern end of this geographic
coalition on this side of i-95 and the
Amtrak Northeast Corridor which connects
all of us the two governor's at the
bottom of my screen are great partners
governor wolf and governor Murphy on
either side of the state of Delaware
really important our coordination and
collaboration but this particular
initiative with respect to purchasing
together PPE and most importantly I
think as governor wolf mentioned a
testing equipment and capacity is so
incredibly important for our small state
like ours to have the purchasing power
Governor Cuomo of New York and New
Jersey and Connecticut and Pennsylvania
in Massachusetts and Rhode Island is
just so incredibly important for us in
terms of getting the right pricing into
you know if we're going to head-to-head
with New York we're not gonna get we're
not gonna get it if we're a long
shoulder to shoulder with you and with
governor fee and governor wolf we've got
a good chance of getting a better price
and getting the product that we need and
I think through all this - the other
thing that was really interesting to me
in joining the coalition was just all
the assets that the other states can
to the table in terms of intellectual
capacity your research institutions your
hospitals because we know that they're
going to be breakthroughs or we hope in
testing and other kinds of technology
that help us as we respond to this so I
couldn't be happier to to be part of
this coalition a part of your leadership
team Governor Cuomo with again my my two
neighbors here in the southern end of
our coalition and to each of you thanks
for the great work that you're providing
to the citizens or your state I tell
people all the time it's gonna be way
harder the decisions we have to make in
reopening our economies in phases than
it was shutting things down in my view
just because of the balance we need to
strike there and we will do that working
together and with the expertise that
this coalition and the purchasing power
in particular of this initiative will
bring to it to the state of Doerr so
thanks very much thank you thank you
John Thank You Governor Carney and
governor Carney is writing the it was
easier to shut down then it's going to
be to reopen shutting down was you walk
into the basement you take the power
switch and you just go from on to wall
alright there was an urgent need it was
an emergency
reopening is more of an art form and I
thank my governor Michael Cooper natori
or colleagues for doing this together we
also have governor Raimondo from the
state of Rhode Island and governor Baker
from the state of Massachusetts who are
part of the coalition you know you go
through situations in life which are
unexpected okay you do your best and
then you learn from them and you grow
and that's what we're trying to do here
today because people expect more from
government than ever before I believe
this has been transformative for a
generation think about when was the last
time government was this vital I don't
know maybe in a war World War two when
government had to mobilize overnight but
for decades you haven't seen government
this essential to human life literally
and government has to work and it has to
work well and it's not for the faint of
heart now and people want government to
perform and government is making
decisions every day that affect their
lives and they deserve the best
government right they're paying for it
they deserve it and they deserve
competence and expertise and smarts and
for government to be doing creative
things and learning like we're doing
here today at the same time government
is working we're trying our best we're
working seven days a week 24 hours a day
we're doing a lot of good work a lot of
creative work but this is not just about
government you know it's too easy to
point fingers but this one has to do
that this one has to do that every
person has a part in this
every person has a part and driving
around New York City today and I was
here yesterday you know we are all are
very thankful to our health care heroes
our frontline workers our essential
workers you watch television the world
is nice commercials thank everyone for
what they did and we should nurses
doctors police officers transit workers
god bless them but if you really want to
say thank you make their life easier by
not getting sick and not making someone
else sick an individual's role is act
responsibly and intelligently for
yourself for your family and for your
community we're a mask
we're a mask I mean that's the basic
step right socially distanced if you
can't socially distance you're in New
York City you're going to
walk up next to a person wear a mask
okay it's not the most attractive
garment ever created
so what well I don't like you know it
feels uncomfortable unnatural so what
you want to honor the healthcare workers
and the people who literally gave their
lives in some cases for what they did
here act responsibly wear a mask I know
the weather is getting warmer I know
people want to get out of the house fine
wear a mask and socially distance that
is your social responsibility in the
middle of this overall pandemic and when
we talk about New Yorkers together and
the spirit of unity and how people are
helping one another and how tough we are
and how smart we are and how disciplined
we are and how we love one another show
it you know how you show love by wearing
a mask please questions you know I don't
know some have said that it's it's not
my field Zak but they say they're two
totally different strains I've heard
from some medical professionals that our
stream was actually more virulent than
the strain that came from China that
whatever the mutation was that happened
in Europe made our strain more virulent
once it comes to New York and again
nobody was anticipating this European
connection you know people from Italy
nobody was saying watch out for those
people from Italy they were just walking
through our airports right we had the
federal officials at all our airports
and they were doing that screening that
they were doing they were screening
people from China still nobody was
screaming people from Europe and the
European travel ban the full-band didn't
go into
or something I admit March we didn't do
a full European travel band so they were
coming nobody was screening nobody was
testing nobody was looking nobody even
knew to look when they wherever they
came in New York nobody was on notice
you know nobody said watch for Italian
people from Italy watch for people from
Ireland and the UK nobody so it was just
we were totally unaware of it then
apparently it's a different stream then
once it gets to New York now you have
that density in New York right and
density is the enemy here and that New
York dense housing dense transportation
then sidewalks in that density it takes
off like a fire through dry grass and
then it spreads it's in New Jersey it's
from Connecticut that whole area but
especially since nobody know I mean
nobody knew right we were doing this
every day
did you nobody ever talked about
transmission through Europe Dave Carlin
CBS 2 I know that like the mask your
eyes you talk about the road to recovery
and reopening as being an art form your
fellow governors feel the same way
how much of this is based on some
personal observations in the last couple
of days and gut instinct as opposed to
the numbers and benchmarks you say are
so important good question
first follow the data I believe you can
do this as a science you know is it
science or is it art let's say it's a
combination but drive it as a science do
it by the numbers you know we're
calculating the spread of the virus
right that is a mathematical equation on
some levels and the more you open the
higher the rate of infection will spread
that is in arguable question is how much
does it spread how fast does it spread
and how fast is it spreading compared to
your healthcare capacity
that is a formula you can plug numbers
into that formula and that's what we're
doing that's the R naught that's the
rate of transmission we want to keep the
rate of transmission below 1.1 we're now
at about 0.7 so we have a margin of
error point seven to 1.1 over 1.1 you're
now an epidemic outbreak status so part
of it is there's mathematical formula
and that's what we're trying to educate
our local partners about in local
government you want to talk about
reopening your region your city your
County etc when will the state reopen my
region well here's the formula plug the
numbers in and look at what the formula
says that's the science of it and with
all this political talk and all these
political opinions I like to stress the
science because it it belies the
politics and the emotion look at the
numbers look at the numbers the art form
is look I've been in the federal
government I've been in state government
that was the Attorney General I did
emergencies in the federal government
all across the nation all across the
world so you bring and educated your
word was gut instinct you bring an
educated gut to what I bring an educated
gut to it because I've gone through this
before but educated gut plus stick to
the science stick to the numbers what
does your gut tell you at the moment
my gut says the weather is going to warm
people are bored people want this over
they see the numbers going down they can
take false comfort oh it's going down
that means it's over no no you never
said it was over we said the numbers are
going down we said roughly a thousand
new people every day walk into the
hospitals oh no it's it's basically over
no well I hear other states are
reopening no we're not out of the woods
and we are this very dense
and you can see that virus pick up
dramatically and it is not going down
it's not it is going down there's no it
we are bringing it down right that
number was going like this the only
reason the numbers not going like this
is because New Yorkers grabbed that
projection curve with two hands and
pulled it down and that's why it went
like this
you go back to your old behavior that
number goes right back up and it's warm
and you want to get out of the house and
everybody's antsy and I haven't gotten a
paycheck and I'm worried about my job I
know but big caution sign to me let's
watch the numbers numbers are going down
but we are a very dense environment
we've had more cases we almost
overwhelmed the whole health care system
so caution moving forward and look how
people cannot wear masks that to me is
even disrespectful it's disrespectful
it's disrespectful to the nurses the
doctors the people who have been
frontline workers the transit workers
you wear the mask not for yourself you
wear the mask for me it's a sign of
respect to other people and you make me
sick that's disrespectful I have to go
into the hospital I have to call an
ambulance that's an ambulance driver I
have to go into an emergency room that's
a nurse that's a doctor who has to put
on PPE that somebody has to buy and pay
for they have to risk being exposed to
the virus because you wouldn't wear a
mask because you wouldn't wear a mask
you put so many people at risk because
you didn't want to wear a mask
I think that's disrespectful by you it's
disrespectful of your relationship and
obligation to one another
yes we're all individuals we're
individuals who live in a community
in the middle of a global pandemic just
be responsible and show respect and I
don't think that's too much for each of
us to ask of one another that's a basic
common decency in this situation and is
it actually safe so long as people wear
masks for people to ideally if you're
protecting yourself and your loved ones
oh by the way if you're a member of a
vulnerable population the ideal is to
stay indoors there's no doubt however
you can't stay indoors forever and the
weather is nice and getting outside
getting some exercise getting fresh air
is good
staying socially distance and wearing a
mask our basic precautions that should
keep you safe not as good as thing in
the house but should keep you safe but
that assumes people around you are
wearing masks people around you are
acting responsibly so it's not even a
situation that you can control yourself
right what happens to you is dependent
on what I do and how I act I don't wear
a mask I sneeze on a park bench you walk
up two minutes later and sit down on the
park bench or by the way you walk up a
half an hour later maybe and sit on the
park bench and you put your hand down
and then you wipe your face now you have
a problem because of me that's why the
mask wearing and on the local law
enforcement I know the New York City I
know mayor de Blasio has made a real
effort I've said to all the local
heads enforce it enforce it because it's
not only wrong a public health risk it
really is such a little thing to ask of
people at a time when people are doing
so much so much
I'm with the transit workers yesterday
they're going train to Train
disinfecting getting on their hands and
knees and hazmat blowing disinfectant
under the seats over the seats on the
ceiling wiping it all down people doing
unprecedented work and you can't even
wear a mask we've said this from day one
right we're in New York State and we're
also operating the state of reality will
you ever get 19 million people in this
state to comply because you give them a
summons no they will comply because they
know the facts and because they choose
and deem that it is intelligent and
reasonable to comply and that's how I've
started this from day one look I could
have done a closed-down order in New
Yorkers could have said that with no
words they could have just not complied
with it right and then what would I do
run around give him summonses it
wouldn't work went through all the facts
explained why and then we close it down
people complied it's going to be the
same with masks and personal behaviors
this is a new level of personal behavior
now that we're asking people to
undertake and I think they will get it I
think it's not going to happen because
of law enforcement but law enforcement
has a role but I think they have to
understand it and they have to get it
and I think of New Yorkers you know the
best the best enforcers of social
behavior or other enforcer are the New
Yorkers right I think
if New Yorkers get it you walk down the
street without a mask I think other New
Yorkers are going to let you know and as
long as they do that within the bounds
of the quorum I don't think that is a
bad thing something regarding PPE and
equipment being manufactured overseas
and would you say that it is time to
maybe I don't know rethink globalization
policies of the direction this country
than going in for the last 30 years I
don't I don't know that you have to go
to globalization policy Zac the you're
not going to change the macroeconomic
forces but I think there is a lesson to
learn and what we're trying to actually
deliver on this is this is a be an
emergency service right in a snowstorm
you have to be able to get solved and
you have to be able to have snowplows
right in a hurricane you have to have
pumps in a public health emergency you
have to have PPE I mean nothing works
unless there's step one is you have to
have the PPE that we have to go to China
for the PPE I mean think about that you
couldn't even get it in this nation we
were started making our own in the state
but that's a national security issue to
me yeah you have to be able to get masks
and gowns and whatever medical equipment
you need so this nation can run a health
care system in the middle of an
emergency yeah yeah I forget the macro
economics just from a national security
point of view I think yes you have to be
able to do that you can't be dependent
on China to have the basic equipment to
save lives in the United States that's
what this came down to I mean Robert
Kraft god bless him owns the New York
New England Patriots New England
Patriots haven't done
New Yorkers a lot of favors over the
years
but great sports team but Robert Kraft
has to send the private plane to China
to pick up masks from Massachusetts
that's how we handle a global pandemic I
have to call mr. Kraft and say can you
do me a favor governor Baker as long as
the plane is going could you pick up
some masks for me I mean that's how that
happened right there two major states in
the middle of a pandemic Robert Kraft is
sending a plane you guys want to comment
on anything no I would just stack on
your point before when you asked about
the higher cases in New York versus the
west coast of the virulent Breland
stream which as the governor said
there's sort of mixed mixed reviews out
there but it's important to remember
it's not just that the triumphs of the
travel ban here didn't happen until I
think it was March 16th after they did
the first version where they closed it
down to most of Europe and then the 16th
was when it went into effect including
the UK whereas they did the Asia travel
ban at the end of January early of
February and so those flights from Asia
go to the west coast the flights from
Europe come to New York and Newark but
look at that variance end of January you
do the China travel ban you don't do the
UK travel ban to the middle of March end
of January to the middle of March the
virus was not hanging out in China
waiting for you during that period of
time January he got on a plane went to
Europe and then spread in Europe and
then from January to mid-march was
coming from Europe right here and I
think on top of that there was this
false sense of security and that they
the CDC was doing testing so they were
coming back and saying there's no cases
in New York but the people that they
were testing they were testing a very
select few that were coming off of
planes from their hot spot designated
regions and then they were letting
everybody else come right through the
front door without doing temperature
checks without checking to see if they
were demonstrating any of the symptoms
that you would have and so I mean
respect what did everyone think was
going to happen yeah according to the
New York Times report last week they
think there were ten thousand seven
hundred cases here in February so
overnight look the subway service will
return when the pandemic ends you tell
me when the pending mackenz I'll tell
you when the subway service resumes but
for that
look we don't we don't really have a
choice in truth most of these issues we
don't have a choice you do what you have
to do we didn't have a choice whether or
not we bought PPE from China we don't
have a choice whether or not we
disinfect the trains I am so grateful to
the frontline workers who show up every
day you know think about what we did
here we had to explain to New Yorkers
how vicious this virus was so they would
actually honor the closed-down this is
what we were just talking about the next
sentence out of my mouth is yes it's
vicious we need to close down next
sentences but I need the essential
workers to come to work tomorrow morning
what you just said it was a vicious
virus I should say home but now the
essential workers have to come to work
yes because we need people to run the
buses and the trains and we need the
nurses and we need the doctors and we
need food on the shelves you want to see
things go bad in a hurry
no food on the shelves right no electric
power you want to see panic and anarchy
you needed those essential workers so
god bless them and we still need them
but at a minimum we're talking about
respect wear a mask they use public
transit I'm not going to ask them to
come to work to get on public transit
unless we know the public transit is
safe and safe in this case
means clean and we talk about the
density as a spreader yeah that's true
but also public transit if it's not
clean can spread right one of the
surfaces that the virus lives longest on
a stainless steel you don't throw those
poles in a subway card you have to clean
the cars and I'm very grateful to the
frontline workers for coming out they
need the public transit we owe it to
them that it's safe and it's clean and
to do that you have to close it down to
one from 1:00 to 5:00 a.m. now what to
5:00 a.m. first time it ever closed down
yeah but also 92% reduction in ridership
so your ridership is down to like eight
percent and 1:00 to 5:00 a.m. is the
lowest period of ridership so people
will work literally in the middle of the
night to clean the trains but it's the
least for the essential workers and for
anyone you know we have to be able to
say we our public transit system is safe
and it is clean and especially getting
ready planning to reopen you cannot do
anything without a public transit system
that people have confidence and knowing
that it is clean and they know how to
disinfect it and they've been
disinfecting it I think that's that's
vital to confidence in New York right
which is a big factor that we have to
put in the equation here just confidence
and comfort with the situation in New
York in the midst of this pandemic right
the multi-state consortium plan
confident the president Trump is still
moving ahead with his offer of the other
things the region's that you need that
promise of 2% of the population testing
or is the multi-state consortium because
we're working with the federal
government whatever they can do to help
is great but this is also an ongoing
situation I don't want to sit here and
just say I'm gonna wait for the help for
help from the federal government
whatever help they give us is great but
it's also clear from the federal
government that it's up to governor's up
the governors up the governors so
whatever we can do on our own so we're
not reliant on anyone that's the best
thanks guys wear a mask in case you
didn't get the mess